c'est un néologisme inventé au 21ème
siècle qui fait couler beaucoup d'encre
le vaccinodromes une infrastructure
pouvant être assimilé à un méga centres
de vaccination certains stades ont
notamment été choisi pour être
transformés en vaccinodromes comme ici à
lyon
des initiatives saluées par le ministre
de la santé le service de santé des
armées va travailler à développer un
certain nombre de grands centres de
vaccination pour les appeler
vaccinodromes ou méga centre quel que
soit le quel que soit le nom il ya au
moins 35 centres qui vont être déployés
à la fois par l'armée les pompiers sur
le territoire national et nous en
déployant avec l'état l'assurance
maladie un certain nombre d'autres aussi
pour pouvoir être capable justement
d'utiliser tous les vaccins qui nous
sont livrés et si aujourd'hui le
gouvernement embrassent cette stratégie
cela n'a pas toujours été le cas
revenons au mois de décembre 2020 alors
que certains de nos voisins comme
l'allemagne lance des vaccinodromes la
france se montre réticente et ce en
dépit des appels d'un certain nombre
d'élus locaux
voici ce qu'en disait le ministre de la
santé lors d'un discours devant les
sénateurs et par ailleurs lorsque nous
vaccinerons population générale certains
élus auront peut-être à coeur de mettre
à disposition des locaux non pas des
immenses vaccinodromes je n'y crois pas
une ferme opposition qui résonne
étrangement à nos oreilles aujourd'hui
alors même que les initiatives de ce
genre se multiplient désormais pourtant
c'est avec aplomb que le même olivier
ferrand déclarait à la fin du mois de
mars
ensuite faut poser et la question des
vaccinodromes ya jamais eu de religion
antibes acquis la drôme donc si on
résume on est passé d'un non catégorique
à la mise en place d'au moins 40 méga
centres de vaccination juste en l'espace
de trois mois
c'est donc ce qu'on peut appeler un
revirement certains élus auront
peut-être à coeur de mettre à
disposition des locaux non pas des
immenses vaccinodromes je n'y crois pas
il n'y a jamais eu de religion anti
vaccinodromes les arguments du ministre
de la santé sur la stratégie locale
déployés au début de campagne peuvent
s'entendre
en revanche comment expliquer que l'on
mise aujourd'hui sur ce qu'on dénigre
est fière sans doute les injonctions du
président de la république ont-elles
pesé sur les préférences de l'ailé vers
an d'ici à la fin de l'été tous les
français de plus de 18 ans qui le
souhaitent pourront être vaccinés
reste maintenant à juger de l'efficacité
de ces vaccins
drôme en termes de communication rien ne
serait pire que d'avoir changé de
braquet pour un résultat médiocre
c'est pourtant ce que redoutent certains
comme raquel garrido enseigne porte
parole de la france insoumise
elle s'inquiète notamment de la
transformation du stade de france en
vaccinodromes ouvert à toute la
population francilienne avec un objectif
de 2000 vaccinations par jour il y aura
un effet aspirateur à vaccins au
détriment des populations fragiles âgées
et isolées du département
si cet effet aspirateur reste à prouver
le touch en tout cas au fond du problème
le gouvernement aura beau ouvrir autant
de vaccinodromes qui le souhaitent
encore faut-il que des doses de vaccin
soit accessible en nombre suffisant